Donald Trump is going to clean is it
there's a Joe Biden to Santa's belly
flop do you you will clean his clock I
don't have a crystal attention and he
set this up months ago by doing an RFP I
have the contractor okay my question he
tried to hire saying he was going to
send people to California this is a
stunt it's embarrassing it's not
pathetic I think he did the right thing
his State's not essentially she did the
right thing by by flying migrants around
even though I can't explain why folks
this is a formidable political force and
this is not about cheerleading Newsome
as the epitome of the progressive
candidate this is about a model for the
Next Generation Democratic movement that
better knows how to deal with these
would-be bullies if you didn't know any
better you'd think that was Gavin
newsom's show and that he was allowing
Hannity to say a few things things which
by the way didn't make a lot of sense